we have to be brave take a chance and
grab them while we can
hey youtubers it's Charlie so big news
king shark is coming back to the flash
and her rumors that was gonna happen but
now it's just been confirmed so David
Ramsey was recently seen at the flash
and air off says they they basically
they share the same office they're like
right next to each other he said that he
was coming back to the flash didn't
really say what it was though and then
finally the producers confirm Diggle and
Lyla will guest star on the flash it'll
be a king shark episode Argus will be
chasing down King shark who has escaped
so I'm assuming that it's still the
earth to king shark that we saw in
episode 4 if you never read it they
actually introduced the character of the
king shark character in the flash season
zero comic book it was a comic book that
was intended to kind of tell stories
that they didn't have time to do on
season one of the TV show but in that
storyline he runs afoul of Amanda Waller
who inducks him into the Suicide Squad
so that's really where most of you
probably know him from is from the
Suicide Squad comics has been a big
character for a long time the origin
story was kind of muddled with for a
while till Aquaman's comic book
explained it fully the way that cleaned
his backstory up is it said he's not
really a mutation he is the son of the
shark God and of course it makes sense
that he would be in an Aquaman title but
they haven't really fully explained what
his origin is going to be on the flash
TV show I assume they're just gonna
sidestep but they're not they're not
even gonna worry about it
usually the default explainer for
mutations or you know people with
special powers metahumans is the
particle accelerator explosion
now David Ramsey supposedly said King
shark was coming back all the way back
during heroes and villains fan fest
during November that's like the earliest
I heard about King shark coming back of
course he's a big character they'd bring
him back no surprise there but now we
know it's gonna be episode 15 Stephen
Amell just came from just for reference
Stephen Amell just confirmed that
they're getting ready to shoot arrow
episode 14 Facebook hello I'm live from
the arrow set what's going on right now
well if I flip the camera around I'd be
in big trouble
nice to be back at work we're finishing
up for 14 that's always the point the
season for me where I actually start to
think about the end game because
typically we do 14 before Christmas and
you never think about the end of the
season until because you don't have a
break but then you come back and you've
done 14 you've got nine to go
I think that's the math it could be
wrong it's all blending together I
actually asked someone what year it was
like in late December I literally didn't
know if it was 2015 or 2016 they're
probably about on the same schedule with
the flash so I would guess they're
getting me ready to shoot this king
shark episode next week not this week
but next week usually I think it takes
him around eight days to shoot an
episode if you guys have been playing
arkham knight his kid actually doesn't
show up king shark has a son named kid
shark that shows up which i think is
kind of funny but I will also say I'm so
so sorry for anybody that bought the PC
version of Arkham Knight they basically
said that there are too many bugs for
them to fix
I think they issued a couple patches
there were some big problems earlier
last year where it was like well the
console versions work just fine but the
PC version complete crap let me know in
the comments though what is your
favorite King shark storyline and how do
you want the TV show to use them in the
future
now obviously he's gonna be a Grodd type
character someone who's just so awesome
that they never kill off but they find
creative ways of bringing back every
once in a while
unfortunately because he's CG it's
really expensive to do them which is why
they don't do Grodd every single week
and it's not really a problem but the
other issue that they run into the arrow
has run into is that they can't do as
many Suicide Squad stories they can do
Argus stories but doing Suicide Squad is
a little bit harder especially with
Amanda Waller because of what the movie
is doing now the really good thing I
know a lot of people always ask this so
I'm like well if the movie does
something does that mean the TV shows
can't do it if it's already been
established on one of the TV shows they
can still do it I think they just can't
do it quite as much so they could
probably still do Amanda Waller I think
it price still do Suicide Squad stories
but I think that DC and Warner Brothers
is encouraging them to look in other
places as far as I know King shark is
not supposed to be in the Suicide Squad
movie he might be in it but I do know
that Killer Croc is this this is Killer
Croc in the Suicide Squad movie and
really I actually I think the TV show
like even though the TV show doesn't
have as much money for visual effects I
think their version of King shark looks
way cooler than Killer Croc does in the
Suicide Squad movie but it's kind of
early to tell usually on big films it
takes a long time to finish visual
effects because there's so much more
complex now I know I said king sharks
back story gets explained a lot in the
Aquaman comics there have been two
Aquaman Easter eggs on the flash TV show
the most
recent one was from Jay Garrick who
basically explained that Atlantis was
above-ground on earth - like he'd
actually been there he had a friend that
was from there so I guess he's friends
with Arthur curry he's basically just
talking about just the society things
it's all Justice Society Easter eggs
because it's earth too but there's also
an outtake from season one of the flash
where Joe talks to Barry about
investigating someone who basically ends
up being Aquaman I believe the way they
described it was investigating a dude
who could talk to fish so yeah basically
just just laying scenes for Aquaman the
same way arrows laying seeds for Green
Lantern probably not gonna have Jason
Momoa on the show anytime soon but it's
just funny to think about I love that
they're able to include things like this
even if they're not going to be able to
show them on-screen that's actually good
question though which do you think that
the TV shows would be able to do first
Atlantis and Aquaman stuff or Hal Jordan
Green Lantern things really I think that
just depends on the state of the film
franchises like if Aquaman turns into
this huge thing which a SMAW MOA they'll
probably be like okay we're just gonna
keep this on the films but really movie
the TV stuff changes every year like the
the rules change all the time so there's
no hard and fast rule that says they'll
never be able to do Aquaman Green
Lantern stuff so you can always hold
that hope Steve which I know a lot of
you the last time King shark showed up
you were like can we have a Grodd versus
king shark episode that would be amazing
that would be like the crazier version
of the flash versus zoom I really think
it's gonna be next year before we see a
gorilla City episode but they do they do
have plans to do that they're like yeah
we're definitely working on it but it's
just so expensive that it takes forever
for them to get the money to do it speed
which that actually reminds me there is
a new round of the reverse flash ring
giveaway this week all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video they're doing
special press for legends of tomorrow
this weekend so they'll probably be a
whole bunch of news dropping on Saturday
and Sunday so I'll be I'll be doing a
new video then in case you guys haven't
seen it already you can click here to
learn all about Deathstorm coming back
for the flash season 2 and you can click
here for all my Star Wars Episode 7
Easter eggs thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight